au canada plusieurs villes et
municipalités interdisent les herbicides
à des fins esthétiques mais certaines
plantes comme le chardon demeure
difficile à contrôler et à edmonton on a
donc troqué les herbicides pour des
herbivores des chèvres et les nouvelles
recrues semblent relever le défi haut la
pâte
[Musique]
c'est l'heure du dîner pour ses 400
chèvres famille au menu aujourd'hui ce
ne sera ni du foin ni de la moulée car
ses chèvres ont une mission bien
particulière à accomplir
[Musique]
c
elles ont été mobilisés pour brouter la
végétation du parc vandall l'un des plus
grands espaces verts d'edmonton
mais attention elle ne mangeront pas
n'importe quelle plante la bergère jen
est aux ordres dirige ses chèvres vers
un secteur du parc rempli de mauvaises
herbes
[Musique]
ckac sports les chèvre broute de façon
méthodique elle commence par manger le
haut de la plante où sont produites les
graines et ensuite elle s'attaque aux
feuilles
elle se déplace continuellement à
l'intérieur d'un secteur en cherchant
les mauvaises herbes
edmonton la capitale albertaine
on cherche depuis quelques années des
solutions écologiques pour entretenir
les espaces verts en 2015 lavez-les
interdite sur son territoire
l'utilisation d'herbicides chimiques à
des fins esthétiques mais pour contrôler
les mauvaises herbes trop invasive ou
qui posent des risques à la santé
publique
elle doit tout de même recourir aux
produits chimiques
les gestionnaires comme olivier le
tinevez dobelle cherche une solution de
rechange et découvre une approche
utilisée en californie le déploiement de
chèvres dans les espaces verts et mange
à peu près 5 kg d'herbe verte par jour
donc vous pouvez voir l'impact 400
chèvres qui vont aller manger chacun 5
kg c'est comme deux tonnes de mauvaises
herbes qui peuvent être à cet accueil au
jt la ville d'hamilton affiche un
nouveau poste celui de course donateurs
municipal de chèvre chinois n'avaient
war l'annoncent devient virale
ces jo leinen qui décroche le poste est
fille unique faisait chier c'est
vraiment un emploi unique coordonnatrice
de chèvre je crois que ça jamais existé
edmonton se cherchent ensuite des
chèvres
[Musique]
janet haut et son troupeau se voit
octroyer le contrat
diplômé en études environnementales
jen est à fonder en 2015 une entreprise
qui se spécialise dans le contrôle
biologique des mauvaises herbes
elle se procure alors quelques centaines
de chefs des animaux bien adapté à
lutter contre les herbes nuisibles
lacets blancs ce que vous voyez ici est
toxique mais l'estomac des chèvres
contient des enzymes qui leur permettent
de digérer la plante et d'en détruire
les graines on les habitue à manger ces
mauvaises herbes en plaçant d'abord de
gâteries dans les auges puis on est
aigre les plans pour la chèvre la
mauvaise herbe devient gâteries gnet
voyage de sept ans c'est avec ces chefs
embauches et surtout par des
municipalités rurales avec son mari
elles passent l'été dans une roulotte
pour surveiller le troupeau
au printemps 2017 gnet reçoit l'appel de
la ville d'edmundston
[Musique]
elle prend avec ses chèvres la route
vers la grande ville
destination le parcours en dehors un
espace vert de 120 hectares où les
mauvaises herbes ont pris le dessus par
endroits c'est le début d'un projet
pilote de trois ans les chèvres cible
quelques plantes en particulier le
chardon l'euphorbe la tanaisie et la
bardane on voit comment la bardane colle
aux vêtements elle s'accroche à tout ce
qu'il effleure les chèvres visitent le
parc une première fois en juin
on veut être là dès le printemps pour
court circuiter le cycle de reproduction
de la plante
du coup ça permet aux plantes indigènes
de se reproduire sans avoir de
compétition
puis elles reviennent en juillet pour
s'attaquer ou re pousse ici hier encore
c'était peas et de fleurs violettes les
chèvres les ont tous brouter empêchant
les plantes de libérer leurs graines
parfois des ajustements sur le terrain
s'impose depuis trois ans nous
travaillons dans un milieu de conifères
et de pain que les chèvres semblait
jusque-là l'ignoré mais on voit
qu'aujourd'hui elle s'y intéresse signe
que leur diète est incomplète
on doit donc ajouter des minéraux à leur
alimentation dans un parc ou si
fréquentes et les chèvres attire bien
des curieux comme il n'ya pas de clôture
les gens peuvent s'approcher des chèvres
thériault à la elles viennent de trouver
un bon endroit
vous allez voir elles sont vraiment
gregan qu'elle rompt toute d'autres
grandes villes canadiennes dont aussi
cette expérience avec des chèvres
le parc maisonneuve à montréal
accueillait quelques chèvres et moutons
à l'été 2010 9 calgary reçoit tout si la
visite du troupeau de janeiro
pour moi c'est important de
conscientiser les habitants de cette
nécessité de prendre ce virage au niveau
de la maintenance des espaces verts à
luton 2019
c'est la dernière visite des chèvres au
parc brandon dans le cadre du projet
pilote
elle n'irait jusqu'aux oreilles
on verra les mauvaises herbes ramper
sous les arbres jusqu'à la rivière
ce serait dangereux de marcher ici
surtout avec tous les déchets caché par
l'herbe le paysage de certains secteurs
du parc est méconnaissable
[Musique]
on voit que les plantes indigènes
prennent le dessus
c'est l'évolution naturelle et c'est
exactement ce qu'on veut
après le départ des chèvres c'est le
temps de faire le bilan
[Musique]
on mesure à l'aide de sursaut la densité
des herbes nuisibles dans le parc a été
nettoyé ces données permettront à la
ville de décider si les chèvres
reviendrons chaque année pour lutter
contre les mauvaises herbes dans six
parcs les gens de ma génération veulent
ce genre de projets novateurs dans leur
ville et leur municipalité
[Musique]
chose certaine les étés de john à tort
risque d'être de plus en plus occupé
je suis débordé de courriels de
questions beaucoup de gens sont curieux
et me demander de vite ripoux warning
crottes
si l'horaire est exigeant elle puise son
énergie dans sa conviction que le
travail accompli par ces 400 company
permet d'assainir peu à peu notre
environnement
je me sens bien quand je pense que grâce
à mes chèvres des litres et des litres
d'herbicides n'ont pas été pulvérisés
sur ses terres je pense qu'il est
vraiment temps de changer notre façon de
faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]